charles dumont est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir monsieur et mon bon soir alors
monsieur legault a dit relativement
jeune
aujourd'hui en parlant de votre âge 47
ans vous êtes à peu près sinon le plus
jeune pdg de l'histoire de la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec
comment vous vous sentez aujourd'hui un
côté je ressens beaucoup de fierté
c'est un énorme privilège de pouvoir
occuper ce poste là de pouvoir servir
les québécois
en même temps je suis conscient ce sont
de grandes responsabilités alors
j'aborde ce mandat avec avec humilité
mais en même temps avec confiance je
vous dirais parce que j'ai la chance
d'avoir une équipe extraordinaire autour
de moi vous diriez que la pointure et
grands de monsieur sidya les chaussures
sont grandes choses aujourd'hui à partir
de maintenant actée mccall accompli de
grandes choses dans l'est dans les dix
dernières années je suis très fier de
pouvoir succéder et bâtir sur son
héritage
j'ai la chance aujourd'hui de prendre
les rênes de l'organisation sur des
bases solides sur des bonnes assises et
puis à ce moment là on va construire là
dessus
alors on reconstruire quoi c'est quoi
votre objectif à partir de maintenant
mais si je pense que si on regarde un
peu ce qui s'en vient devant nous force
est d'admettre que la prochaine décennie
et va être différente de la dernière on
a deux bénéficient comme vous savez de
vent de dos très favorable à mme est
maintenant ici devant nous je pense
qu'un consensus
un peu partout que pour aller chercher
des rendements mais va falloir
travailler encore plus fort ces actifs
l'aujourd'hui sont plus chers
les taux sont bas il ya énormément de
capital qui cherche à trouver les mêmes
actifs alors il va falloir être agile en
même temps demeure et résilients parce
qu'on sera testé à un moment donné ou un
autre parce qu'on s'attend à un
ralentissement économique peut-être une
récession on s'attend à ce que
l'embellie boursière du marché des
actions finissent par s'arrêter écrit je
dis pas qu'il ya une récession l'année
prochaine mais c'est certain qu'à un
moment donné c'est le plus long cycle
économique qu'on a connus depuis fort
longtemps
puis je donne toujours la statistique
suivante les marchés se tenir
pratiquement connu la meilleure année
des 30 dernières années des rendements
de 25 30%
toutes les classes d'actifs ont
pratiquement monte alors que les profils
entreprise il sur la cnpie sont restés
assez stables 0% de croissance
donc comme on dit les arbres ne montent
pas jusqu'au ciel ouais est ce à dire
que ce rendement annualisé depuis dix
ans 9 à 10 pour ça on connaît on peut
pas s'attendre à ça pour les prochaines
années
mais je pense qu'il faut simplement
s'attendre à devoir déployer encore plus
d'efforts et se battre pour chaque point
de rendement il ya des moyens de le
faire s'agit juste d'avoir une offre de
services d'avoir des gens qui ont des
expertises complémentaires aux gens
actuellement la caisse qui crée de la
valeur aux niveaux atteints des
opérations de l'entreprise assuré que
les entreprises peuvent avoir prendre le
virage numérique vont avoir des gens qui
ont une expertise au niveau
technologique
j'essaie vraiment de revoir un peu notre
bassin de talents formés nogent prendre
en considération la technologique avoir
d impact énorme sur notre portefeuille
et puissent ajuster au fil du temps en
quoi votre expérience parce qu'au fil du
temps depuis 25 années mots clés dans
votre histoire ces fusions acquisitions
investissement les entreprises les
acquisitions notamment en quoi ça
pourquoi on va vous chercher aujourd'hui
ça va vous servir à partir de maintenant
à la caisse de dépôt mais je pense que
évidemment les actifs réels tout les
placements privés tout le transactionnel
ou à ce qu'un élément transactionnel as
été mon métier pendant de nombreuses
années j'ai eu la chance également de
gérer la partie de marchés des capitaux
dans ma carrière précédente à la banque
scotia donc je pense que j'ai une bonne
connaissance des marchés
je pense également que je mène une
perspective intéressante du fait que je
connais le québec inc
je l' ai servi pendant 25 ans dans mon
rôle même quand j'étais à l'extérieur du
québec
je garde un contact à toutes les
semaines avec les entrepreneurs ici avec
les sociétés mais j'ai vu le québec j'ai
vu le regard qu'on pose sur le québec
de l'extérieur si je pense que ça me
plaise avait vu ben je pense qu'on doit
être fier en tant que premièrement le
regard qui j'étais cette organisation
lutte extraordinaire un sonic une
organisation qui se distingue de
plusieurs façons par rapport à ses pairs
le double mandat le développement
économique et de rendement c'est un
leader là
qu est maintenant dans l'adn de
l'organisation toute cette notion
d'investissement durable donc on va voir
rester à l'avant garde de tout ça quand
on regarde le québec c'est une société
pour laquelle les gens beaucoup
d'admiration m'en parlait beaucoup
alors je pense que je capable d'amener
cette approche tout terrain que je
connais ici au québec avec ce réseau là
c'était contre ce thème là en même temps
une perspective globale
on dit souvent que françois legault puis
se décrit lui même le premier ministre
comme étant un nationaliste économique
êtes vous un nationaliste économique
avec lui je pense que c'est important de
veiller à ce que nos entreprises
québécoises aient les moyens qu'on
puisse les appuyer pour se développer au
grossir pour elle à l'international donc
c'est certain que pour moi ça s'est
inscrit dans la continuité de ce que la
caisse a fait ça va bien au québec
actuellement l'économie va bien comme
jamais donc cette peser sur
l'accélérateur qui continue et fait
ressortir des nouveaux champions de
nouvelles économies et des nouveaux
champions ou des nouveaux fleurons
oui si je vous dis protéger les fleurons
du québec
vous me répondez quoi mais les sièges
sociaux les qu'on appelle c'est évident
c'est très très important ça c'est
indéniable puis un consensus là dessus
mais moi j'aime amener le débat sur le
fait que ça c'est une réalité c'est une
action qu'on pose à tous les jours dans
le quotidien la mer défensive
c'est l'offensive donc amener des
solutions nos sociétés leur présenter
des acquisitions des cibles à
l'extérieur grossir avoir des projets
dans certains cas regardez plutôt qu'est
ce qui pourrait être une vulnérabilité
mais ça se fait tous les jours pas
seulement dans un cadre transactionnel
et puis je dirais faut en créer de
nouveaux à voir cette pépinière pas ce
qu'il va en avoir des nouveaux dans la
nouvelle économie
etes-vous le pdg de la caisse qui va
sortir la caisse des énergies fossiles
on pose déjà souvent cette question là
aujourd'hui ce virage là y'a déjà était
amorcée significativement qu'on appelle
décarbonisation carbonisation duction de
l'intensité des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre mais aussi sortir des énergies
fossiles
évidemment sortir des énergies fossiles
il ya plusieurs sources d'énergie ou
est-ce qu'on est déjà un point
différents l'un de l'autre qu'on va
continuer dans la même direction une
question
rythme mais c'est certain que la
destination inconnue siège de le faire
intelligemment pour les déposants même
temps êtes vous inquiet de ce qui se
passe chez bombardier
mais bombardier vous savez c'est une
société cotée en bourse donc je peux pas
commenter normes et man est ce que je
peux dire c'est que c'est un
investissement important pour la caisse
au sein de bombardier transport et qui
vont évidemment on suivait la situation
de près on n'ira pas plus loin
c'est ça c'est plus difficile ok
dernière question sur leur m
est-ce que ce modèle du rem qui a été
développé à la caisse de dépôt vous
voulez le multiplier ailleurs mais je
pense que ce qu'il faut réaliser en
pense qu'en premier lieu ce qui est
important c'est de bien livré ce projet
si ça c'est la priorité
par la suite est-ce que c'est un modèle
exportable possiblement on a créé
clairement une expertise mais ce que je
veux faire maintenant c'est livrer un
projet en bonne et due forme
atteint à l'intérieur des coûts pour les
montréalais qui on verra par la suite si
possible de pour exporter ce savoir
faire long c'est un plaisir de vous
rencontrer
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup au revoir
à la prochaine